refléter cette hausse, mais
ils doivent le faire sans
effrayer leurs clients!
Jean-Philippe Hughes.
- Salle bondée, ambiance
décontractée et des plats
qui donnent l'eau à la bouche.
La cheffe propriétaire Caroline
Dumas tente d'absorber ses coûts
croissants, mais la facture est
de plus en plus salée.
CAROLINE DUMAS, cheffe
propriétaire, Bloomfield
- Ça, avant la pandémie, c'était
14 $, et maintenant je l'ai mis
à 17. Et normallement,
je devrais peut-être
le vendre 20.
(rires)
- La note au restaurant va
bondir en moyenne
au pays en 2022, selon le
rapport de Restaurants Canada.
Pour joindre les deux bouts,
plus du tiers des salles
à manger comptent même monter
les prix de 10 à 15 %.
KARINE PENOT, cliente
- C'est - C'est - C'est quand me
consistante. Parce qu'on sort
pas mal quand même ici.
Je pense que personnellement,
oui, ça fera peut-être moins
de restaurants.
- Le principal responsable,
c'est le prix des aliments
qui a augmenté de près
de 10 % en juillet par rapport
à l'année dernière.
- Regarde, tu vois ici,
j'ai des noix, puis
normallement, ça, juste avant
la pandémie, c'était 13,99.
Ça, c'était fascinant, parce que
je le voyais augmenter. C'était
rendu 16,99, puis là, maintenant
aujourd'hui, c'est 18,99.
OLIVIER BOURBEAU, VP fédéral
et Québec, Restaurants Canada
- Nos fournisseurs, leurs
augmentations sont encore plus
élevées que ça. On s'attendait
même à une hausse, à être
obligés de hausser les prix
un peu plus haut que ça.
- C'est sans parler des salaires
croissants dans un secteur
où il manque plus
de 170 000 travailleurs.
- Vraiment, les salaires ont
augmenté de 25 % à peu près,
et il n'y a pas beaucoup
de main-d'oeuvre.
- Dans ce restaurant rapide
grec, Maria Voutsinos sait très
bien que sa clientèle cherche
les petits prix. Les siens
ne suivent pas l'augmentation
du coût de l'huile à friture,
notamment.
MARIA VOUTSINOS, copropriétaire
Taka Taka
- On n'a pas le choix
d'augmenter un petit peu.
Mais on ne peut pas augmenter
trop, sinon la clientèle,
c'est un problème.
- Actuellement, un restaurant
moyen a une marge bénéficiaire
d'environ 2 à 3 % uniquement,
donc vous comprenez que pour
nous c'est très, très difficile
d'arriver actuellement.
- Comme d'autres, elle absorbe
une partie de la facture pour
demeurer compétitive,
en attendant que la surchauffe
économique se calme un peu.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hugues,
Radio-Canada, Mon